Okay, now I want to show you something really crazy,
that's going to make it immediately clear how cool SVMs can be.
So, what I'm showing you here are two different SVMs,
this one you just made, and this is one that I just made.
You don't know how yet, but
we're going to spend a lot of time talking about this.
Look at how intricate this decision boundary is,
you have little pockets and you have little peninsulas that reach out.
You can see an SVM can do some really complicated shapes to
the decision boundary, sometimes even more complicated than you want.
So, let's go talk to Sebastian again.
And he has some pretty interesting insights as to
how this is coming out of a classifier.
Remember, the SVM is a classifier that's built on giving us linear separation,
so how on earth can it give us this incredibly non-linear decision boundary?
Well, that's something Sebastian's going to explain to you now.